all right folks I make it three o'clock
so I'm
gonna start I realize people are
filtering in but I you know got a
housekeeping and Preamble so we'll just
get through that
my name's Ian Cooper
uh you can find my socialist there
we have we have Twitter uh I post less
there now and we have uh Mastodon
for those of you that are
have kind of joined an exodus from
Twitter
to Mastodon uh given the hillsides
become even more of a Health site
this talk is really about the idea of
reactive architectures
and how we can use some of those ideas
and what it means
when we think about building our own uh
distributed systems
who am I most of this just says that I
have a big gray beard and I'm quite old
and I've been doing this for a fair
amount
I I currently work at just eat takeaway
um locals can blame me for A
non-delivery of their food if they wish
uh uh uh at the point I always raise is
the one at the bottom right I and some
other folks in this room got started
speaking because we started the.net User
Group in about 2003 when there literally
were no experts so we had to give talks
ourselves
and as a result of that we kind of
got past that initial hurdle of fear uh
about standing up in front of other
people and talking
uh and that went on to enable us to
start speaking at conferences et cetera
around the world
um and I would encourage any of you to
consider doing it and any of you may
think to yourself I have nothing to say
that's because you think about the
things that you and your peer group know
there are people who want to not want to
learn from you about the things that you
know
they are valuable to somebody else
perhaps at an earlier stage of their
career
so please do uh step up if you feel like
it
I work on an open source project any.net
developers in the room
yeah hello to you all right so we are an
alternative to mass transit and service
bus
uh I can't remember what Jerry Miller's
now renamed his as Wolverine or
something we are an alternative
messaging and uh mediator style
framework
all right what am I going to talk about
today
I'm going to have a little diversion
into objects
I'm sure we all know about objects but
have a little diversion and talk about
how objects may have colored our
thinking of the world
and then I want to look at how reactive
and its ideas may give us a different
way of thinking about how we build
distributed systems today
reactive is mostly not based on
particularly new ideas
uh so we'll talk about some ideas like
data flow actor flow-based programming
they're all really date from about the
1970s
like many ideas from the 1970s
we were visiting them because they
they were kind of ahead of their time
they didn't they didn't they weren't
really successful but when we move into
a modern context of multi-core
architectures distributed computing it
turns out some of the ways these ideas
were working are incredibly valuable to
us in changing our perception about how
we do stuff
so we'll look at a few of those old
ideas and then we'll try and address
this idea of what people mean by the
idea of reactive architectures and how
these old ideas play out
for us in trying to build systems that
have properties are being resilient
elastic and responsive
objects I'm sure everyone in the room
knows about objects right
so we have a class and the class
encapsulates some data
right generally well most of our data to
be in private fields
and then there is some
behavior that it exposes
and normally
there's coupling between this behavior
in this state
right
the state that we need in order to
exercise this Behavior or alternatively
the behavior the the behaviors that are
associated with knowledge of this state
are kind of coupled together in a class
and then we may choose to compose
classes by having you know the fields
beer class themselves we might in the
bad old days of thought we'd inherit
from behavior from another class we do
that less now because that turns out to
be very fragile
but we've got this orientation of data
and behavior living together
and generally you know we talk about
this being message parsing what they
really mean is I call it a method
there's some parameters to message in
and it gives me a response message out
I might decide they're called Dynamic
dispatch right I'm not too worried about
that it just this idea of effectively
you might call
from a clip from a base method on a
clock of something you inherit from but
we're all about objects right
right
so when we first started to build
component architectures service oriented
architectures is really kind of an early
name for these component architectures
but there are lots of them even before
SOI really we had you know com and Corb
or Etc
the dominant Paradigm was objects
so this is basically you look at kind of
SOA to the lens and say wisdle
so we still had an idea effectively when
I got a service
and there's some operations on it
and the operations are things I I can
send in a message and return a message
it's like a method on a class really the
just the parameters we sent to the
operation and return value
right and it had some data
we had the kind of four tenets of SOI
and we said oh yeah well basically what
happens is the class basically hides all
the data and then they provide
operations on it and then wisdor had
things like an end point and a binding
right often called the ABCs address
binding and contract
um that let us expose basically this
service to other people classically
usually there was an H there was a URL
and we bound soap in order to basically
reveal this thing to the outside world
but what that led us down the path of
was tending to think of our systems when
we broke them up in terms of I want
loads of little objects with their
behavior
so typically when we thought maybe about
an e-commerce application as an example
we might think oh well I need I have
restaurants and I can create and read
and update and delete restaurants so I
need a restaurant service and I have
accounts for customers and I create and
read and I update delete accounts so I
have an account service and so on and so
on and so on and so on
that tends to be a little bit of a
problem
we get a couple of negative
characteristics on that and they also we
also get them in oh to be honest with
you
and one of them is this idea of feature
Envy
if I tend to have these object-like
services
what is the logic tend to go that uses
these services with their operations
on the client
maybe in some kind of API Gateway right
maybe effectively it drifts all the way
down
to one of the first services like car
I've got a shopping cart
that becomes a kind of God service that
says don't worry
when someone wants to basically make an
order I've got all the business logic
I want you tender to find an SOI which
that we ended up with these services
that were very much
you know most of these things just do
crud
and the shopping cart has all of the
domain Logic for REO Commerce
application
and that's kind of negative right
because really we kind of know that
that's going to cause problems for
maintenance
because every time somebody wants to
make a change this gold component's got
to change right so the god service has
to change every single time
and that isn't really what we meant by
autonomous components or independent
deployability or all those things that
were supposed to bring us the the dream
of our teams being able to work
independently of each other
and this oo Paradigm that we were kind
of pushing forward has kind of fooled us
a bit right and in some cases they used
to joke to people and say well if I've
just I've got an account database that
I'm doing crud on it and it's actually
over a store like dynamodb that has a
rest interface anyway
what does my service actually do
why not just call Dynamo
but we see a lot of these Services out
there that are really when you reduce
them to what they're actually doing
they're just a thin wrapper over the API
of the database
the other problem is that they tend to
work via RPC
or a synchronous conversation let's say
because quite a lot of them also work
for our http
and the problem with that is that faults
propagate
if I lose my menu service
and it turns out the camp can't get a
hold of the menu anymore and it probably
can't price the order that you've given
me for my food for your food takeaway
so as soon as menu stops working
everything stops working
I became vulnerable in terms of my
availability to customers
to the least good coder in the
organization
right your uptime is the worst
programmer you have
because when his code fails the whole
house of cards comes down and your team
working on the restaurant service you
may have built something that you know
you've you're pretty sure it's resilient
as hell but it's useless to you
if the guy who's working on menu
you know had a bad day
and the code is pretty useless
so we get these problems and some of
them are really to do with the Paradigm
of hey it's just really a big object
that we talk to basically via often you
know grpc because then it looks like a
procedure call right I just thought
that's just an object I'm using remotely
this kind of remote objects paradigm
has kind of killed or attempted the
autonomous components a lot
so the 1970s reactive was really a kind
of alternative to the dominant Paradigm
really about Von Nema machines but then
in later on essentially against other
programming paradigms and they they
fought a continuous struggle against
things like object orientation and in
many cases they lost right although
there are successful examples of the
systems that emerged they didn't they
didn't become mainstream to a large
extent until we got into stupid systems
later
I'm going to warn you I I don't want to
talk today about specific
implementations so there are lots of
tools out there which would bad to
themselves as reactive tools you know RX
reactive streams
um active Frameworks like erlang akka
akka.net or whatever right let's talk a
lot about that
um so that's what you want there's still
time to run away uh I'm not going to get
into the depths of a specific
implementation what I want to look at is
the principles that reactive programming
had and how we can apply those
principles to how to build distributed
systems any one of those tools may be
helpful to you or none of those tools
may be helpful to you don't need any of
those tools to implement these ideas
right
so what is reactive a reactive can be
divided in a couple of things reactive
programming which is what we had in the
1970s things like data flow programming
actor models flood-based programming
and reactive systems this is this modern
concept which is really a whole load of
if you like principles and patterns that
you can use for Implement distributed
systems but they all have a core idea
um and this quote really comes from a
via uh Paul Morrison uh JPM who bases
The Man Behind flow-based programming uh
my Greek is terrible it's something like
tarpanta Ray Kai uden maina which it
just means uh everything flows pantare
and nothing stays
the Greeks in the audience can tell me
how badly I've mangled that I apologize
to anyone who's Greek
um
the idea is a quote from her collectors
who is a philosopher
um is that we should really be focusing
on flow
on the on the passage of things
rather than on these little isolated
entities
okay
so data flow programming is one of the
kind of oldest beasts in this space
and it says
what we want to do is think about our
program
as a graph
and in our graph there are nodes
and at those nodes some kind of behavior
happens
right some kind of transformation
and between those nodes over the
vertices
flows data
and so I want to not join these two
concepts together but kind of separate
them the idea of saying hey data is
flowing through my program and then it
reaches these particular nodes things
happen and you can pretty much program
anything using this model right you can
program addition right
number hits the node another number hits
the node either two nodes either two
together put the result out basically
from the note right
so these things work to basically let us
do
complex programming problems
and generally when you see dataflow
programming today those of you who are
DOT net there's quite a few of you those
things like TPL dataflow Liam has got to
talk properly somewhere on the internet
you can find if you want to try to learn
about TPL dataflow is that one with the
kettles Liam I can't remember
okay
um uh so you guys have a node and the
node you're going to think of as a black
box a unit of computation
and my node has kind of input and output
which anything has ports so some data
comes in
the Black Box performs some magical
transformation
and an output goes out I push a push a
kind of answer out onto the wire
typically
what tends to happen is I create an
instance of the node because there is
some work available
on the input
do the work
push the answer
close down basically that particular
node right so I respond to there being
work
some of you may think about dataflow
programming and that idea of saying hey
I've got this whole set of jobs to do
data flow programming lets me spin up
things to do those jobs but really what
we're trying to focus on data flow
programming is this idea of a flow of
work and Transformations you are
performing upon it
and the key is
the data growth can be anything pretty
much data programming has no real
restrictions right it could be simple
flat data or it could be Primitives it
could be compound structured
unstructured doesn't really matter right
the key is I can begin to chain these
things together
so I can get about I can click little
simple behaviors that are easy to
understand
and I can chain them into more complex
behaviors the poster child for this is
obviously the Unix command line right
where I got little programmers that do
things and I pipe the output into other
things but we can write programs like
that well we just have little simple
Transformations and we just basically
push work through all these
transformations
so we can be synchronous or asynchronous
here
so in synchronous basically what happens
is the thread of execution flows down
the chain or we can be asynchronous
which tends to require buffering
and what tends to happen there is
essentially each component when it puts
an uh puts out its answer puts it onto a
buffer so the next component doesn't
have to be available at that point in
time it just picks up the work when it's
ready from the buffer
and that allows
data flow programming
to work basically in parallel right so
we can add these various steps working
in parallel with each other so it's an
easy model
of basically using multiple cores in an
architecture or even in a modern world
using multiple
uh
systems because effectively the idea is
that this individual item can be simple
and single threaded
the multi-threading comes from running
them all in parallel
and they just simply read work off the
buffer
typically when we can think about push
or pull sometimes hot or cold is another
word for the same thing are we
effectively observing something that is
essentially spitting out data and we're
just listening to it uh canonical
example is usually a mouse moving around
generating in Windows I think it's WM
Mouse move messages right or are we
effectively saying to something by a
pull hey please start sending us
information about X
we also tend
in data flow programming to say the
output buffer because it has a fixed
capacity should not be full
if I effectively want to read
in other words if I'm going to do the
work there's got to be supposed to be to
put the work out there
and that allows to be a replacement
called back pressure right that says hey
if the downstream is all jammed up the
Buffer's got full it can't work as fast
as we can
we should pause
and wait until it's done some work
freed up some space on its buffer
on our output buffer it's input buffer
right freed up some space
and then let us write
this basic idea of back pressure says we
want to essentially prevent things being
overwhelmed
because if they're working in parallel
that could be working at quite different
rates and ultimately we're all subject
to the law which I can't remember examin
does law which basically says you know
our overall throughput is limited to the
throughput of the slice component in our
chain
so classic lifetime is essentially as we
said
um
I've actually lived long enough to
basically calculate the answer
and capacity
is essentially that these buffers have
capacity they're not infinite
I mean the theory in maths you could
probably make them infinite in Practical
Computing resources that never happens
and you have back pressure by not
basically taking work off an input queue
until there's space on the output keeps
you to write stuff
now a nice advantage of this model
is that we tend to benefit from being
Loosely coupled
because these individual components
are only coupled by data
okay quick recap
doubling some various examples of tight
versus loot coupling content coupling is
I know about your code your schemas
everything else common coupling is we
both share some global data that could
just be a big database table
control copying is I have certain Flags
or signals I send you to control the
behavior the way you do stuff which so
your internal behavior is it has a
dependency on the flags that I know
about right
stamp coupling is where essentially you
only use a portion of the data that I
send there are fields that are
effectively unused
data coupling which is kind of the
weakest form of coupling says we're both
coupled by the schema the data that's
passing between us
we have to have some coupling in life I
mean not necessarily but it tends to be
nowadays that machines running in locked
basements with no connection to the
internet are pretty useless for any real
work so we tend to have some form of
coupling to other things right in order
to be useful necessary coupling
so data if we're going to choose some
coupling is a good form
one of the other ideas that reactive
program was trying to get into is actors
what are actors about it's one of those
words but like
um
monoids that people get frightened by
so Edgar Dykstra basically said hey
sometimes we have mutable state
and sometimes we have multiple threads
and it would be really bad if the
threads altered that mutable state in
the wrong order how do I stop that oh I
know I'll have some means of doing
synchronization some kind of gate tend
to think about semaphores monitors Etc
which means that we serialize access to
that mutable state
right only one thing can affect the
mutual State at a time
and that was the dominant Paradigm here
how we did multi-threaded code for how
we protect mutable state from being
basically uh corrupted by
multiple threads running at the same
time and you have probably written or
used code that essentially uses a
semaphore or a monitor in order to
protect basically mutable state
the answer modeler says well we could
look at the kind of data flow
programming model and if we should say
that our node is single threaded
then our node the single thread is the
only thing that can update the mutable
state
then if effectively I think of my input
buffer as a kind of inbox
then I can protect access to that
mutable state
because essentially there's only one
thread ever altering it and it's just
stepping its way through the work
requests in the inbox
so I don't need a synchronization
primitive of any sort
because effectively this model
gives me synchronization over my mutable
state
so this is basically Carl Hewitt and he
called this the actor model but really
it's just a variation of data flow
programming an actor is just a dataflow
node it's just taking advantage of the
fact that if I make my node single
threaded
I can sequence the changes to the
mutable state that it protects
actors have some basically rules around
them uh actors can send messages to
other actors they can create new actors
they know the addresses of actors
um and they can basically communicate
that dress of actors why do you don't
worry too much about that why do you
care the main reason you care is because
obviously if I think about the fact that
I'm protecting Mutual state in an actor
I might have lots of mutable state that
I want to sequence access to how do I do
that well generally the idea is that I
can partition
all these actors their own part to the
mutable State and I've actually wrote
requests to the right actor to
essentially update the relevant piece of
beautiful state right
so that's really how actors scale
obviously if I have one thread and it
was I want to get you a long way and we
we underestimate how fast one thread can
be but it may be too slow and in which
case I need to partition my state
and work with one threat instead
I'm just as an aside on this I mean we
we build systems you think things like
Kafka every day right and on a Kafka
partition you have a single thread
you only have to have one third ready
from a partition at a time because you
have to retain ordering
and I can't retain ordering if I have
multiple threads
because I have multiple threads there's
no guarantee as it reads item off the
queue that it won't purchase them out of
sequence
so Kafka says hey you're given partition
on a stream only one thread gets to read
it
what we do is we take that stream and we
slice it into a number of pieces
well technical consistent hashing which
basically says given a restaurant has an
ID it always goes into this particular
bucket
so that I can always process updates to
it in order
so I get away with having one thread
so we build production systems all the
time in a single threaded approach and
single threaded code is simple and easy
to write because I don't have to worry
about multi-threading concerns in the
code itself what I do is rely on the
partitioning to give me that single
threaded approach right and a Kafka
stream a partition on a Kafka stream is
effectively a mailbox
which I can read
to get work I update right
right so I'm not specifically using an
actor model but the same understanding
about how a stuff works is useful to
understand to apply
flow-based programming so flabase
programming is probably
less well known than the other two
anyone who heard of flow-based
programming in the room before
today okay poor old JPM
flowbridge program is another form of
data flow
um it's got some interesting ideas so
it's worth raising it as well as data
flow
so I have uh no just like in data flow
it has ports ports generally name
dataflow programming and if I press
program another and one of the reasons
port's a named is because within your
code running inside the node you just
address a named Port you say basically
hey receive from the port called in
Center the port mod out you give you
tend to give more meaningful names but
in and out will do us for a high level
and then what that lets us do is say you
internally don't know anything about the
connector it's external to you the thing
that connects you to other nodes
so it could be replaced by something
else right it might be in memory in one
environment but actually in your
production environment it's a rabbit m
key message queue
okay so that's one idea that it brought
in sorry named ports and really when we
think about channels in messaging which
are really we talk about being a virtual
pipe with a logical named address it's
really just another version of this idea
from flow-based programming of a named
port with an external connector Beyond
it
and the idea in Flight waste programming
is we have information packets data
and it flows between nodes and those
nodes of black boxes to perform some
kind of transformation on it
and the result of that basically is work
right
so information packets essentially are
deleted from the buffer you're written
from buff you delete them
you process your work and you put a new
information packet out on the file so I
representing the transformation
and messaging quite often we talk about
cues versus streams streams from like
Kafka we have an index it's effectively
an append only stream and we just
basically record How Far We've read we
we keep a track of how far up this
streamer have I read and we tend to
store that something called an offset
and a queue
we tend to actually lock the next item
on the Queue we read part of it already
locked we delete that item off the queue
the cues are much more similar to the
way that flowbase programming works and
it says it says delete that incoming
piece of work so nobody else processes
it it's done
and move it along
so the node essentially in uh flow-based
programming can actually suspend so
rather than the dirty flow programming
model where effective we spin one up
push some work through it shut it down
and then next when the next item will
work spin another one up employment's
programming we're allowed to actually
suspend it we have to say there's no
work so just I'll just pause doing
nothing until some more work arrives and
I can send you an explicit kill signal I
say basically hey there's no more work
to do you can you can kind of give up
and shut down now right
and with capacity in flow-based
programming as well as the decision to
say hey there's no capacity on the
output
so effectively I don't want to basically
send you something in other words back
pressure I can also do load shedding
floatburst programming says you know
what if you receive an input and there's
no room on the output you're perfectly
entitled to dump the input
and that can be useful
so think about context for example we
have information packets all the time
from Riders who are out there trying to
deliver your food
if I miss some of those it doesn't
really matter because I'll get another
signal a bit later telling me where it
is all you'll see is that the rider
seems to jump on the map like they're
teleported that's simply because we've
just dumped some information packets
because we're feeling overwhelmed right
it doesn't really matter to you at some
point we'll catch up and then we'll show
you where somebody is so load shedding
is a viable option at some points
um there's some rules uh if I'm writing
to basically an output Port I only get
to do that on one thread so as to
provide preserve ordering
but many people can write to an input
thread but obviously effectively that
will impact the ordering of those things
that I have okay
other interesting ideas uh
information initial information packets
so when I start up my node I can add
basically a port where I read a single
packet and that packet tells me how to
configure myself
anyone program with mqtt and iot devices
a few people so mqt has a similar the
mqtt has a similar notion of an
international information packet lets
you configure
a consumer when it starts up to start
receiving messages
control packets or brackets as they're
sometimes called this idea that I have a
sequence of messages I want you to
process where I give you basically
initial
control packet sometimes called an
opening bracket a whole set of messages
that then relate to that particular
particular piece of work and then a
closing bracket packet which basically
says that's the complete set of work
that you need
but another one will come back to it's
under a lookup table
so the idea that says I might need some
data
in order to do my work
that data
could be generated by another node
and what I do is I listen to the message
the output Port of that other node
and I put basically the results of its
work into a table
then I can go and look it up
so I want to go and look up prices of
food
there may well be a node a where
effectively you're entering changes
basically to to menu item prices
it does I don't know some calculations
on vat or whatever effectively and gives
you the final and our service charges it
gives you the final price and you'll
look up node says I take that and I just
write it into a database
and then when B which is doing some
pricing of an order for a customer
comes along with basically a customer's
order is its information packet
it can use the lookup table
to figure out the price
and what that stops the need for us to
do
is to call a to send it a message saying
can I have the price for X can I have
the price for y and keep sending it
matches because we have to suspend the
workflow in B for that pricing item
while we wait for the request response
to come through
so if we pre-build that lookup table
it makes it very easy to do that pricing
we'll come back to that idea
okay
a drink of water it's not a budget truck
you don't drink in some water
so what are active systems and how do
these 1970s ideas
how do they help us
so there's a big document don't worry
you're not trying to read that you can
go and find it on the Internet it's
called the reactive Manifesto
it was written by Jonas Bonner I think
that's probably about pronouncing it and
a whole load of other people you have
probably heard of helped
um and their idea was that whole lot of
people were working on similar sorts of
ideas and they wanted to produce a
Manifesto that talked about what they've
perceived as a better way of building
distributed systems
and so to Define what you can think of
as an architectural style called
reactive applications
and they had some rules right
so how the world that they should react
to events
and this event in a sense that is
basically the definition of reactive for
them it reacts to events
all that'll let you do
is think about basically reacting to
load by being scalable
being resilient to failure
and being responsive to users
so generally the Mantra is that
effectively they are responsive
resilient elastic and message driven
don't worry about the detail you'll go
through this a few times in the next few
seconds
and you can find it there
so this is kind of the diagrammatic
version which is a little bit easier to
read
by the means of being message driven
we obtain the properties of being
resilient and elastic
which enables us to be responsive to
users
that's effectively what they're driving
it
okay
so reactive systems use message passing
and we what does it mean by that they're
going to send you know have an
asynchronous conversation between any
two components it may or may not be
messaging middleware right
and effectively what we're saying is hey
I'm going to send you a message and when
you're going to do your work and you're
going to basically send a message out as
a result of doing that work it might be
a reply to me or it might simply be a
signal to the next person in the chain
so effectively there are a couple of
things that might be going on you're
probably receiving a message and it's
one or two options look on the bottom
you've either been given a command right
you're being told to do something
or you're being given facts things you
should know typically messaging we think
that is as a command I'm telling you to
do something well often my common
example is make me a cup of tea
and things that basically you know you
may be given facts on Ian's tea
preferences right Ian likes his T white
he doesn't like any sugar he prefers
basically English breakfast under no
circumstances give him Earl Gray
it I'll create a dirty dishwasher this
dishwater is not tea
all right so typically these components
that receive these commands or events
the when we think of them in terms of
distributed systems we tend to call them
services
we should think about them transmit
provide doing transformations in
response to these pieces of data they
receive
often what you're looking for is
something you can name as a verb noun
combination I do this to this
right I place an order I onboard a
restaurant
you don't want a restaurant service you
want an onboarding restaurant service
that's what we do we onboard restaurants
onto our platform
and so what you want to think about is
what it what what transformation are you
performing
in this process
and then like data flow programming but
you really change these together in a
flow
so here potentially I have said You know
here is a customer purchase
I want to check out the purchase or
probably in this case you might want to
rephrase that as I want to price and
validate the purchase
so take your purchase your basket of all
the items that you've ordered
I figure out the pricing I apply any
offers I validate that essentially maybe
that stuff's in stock
and then I say oh I need to take a
payment for that
so I send this priced order because now
I can take a basically payment for it
onto the next component which
essentially is going to price it
typically what you're looking for when
you're influenced by this reactive model
is things that you can run in parallel
your one service you don't want to be do
it to be doing things
that could be done in parallel
because it's much easier
split out the thing that could be done
in parallel into a new node send a
message to it because then essentially
you could potentially think about making
that component single threaded
it's going to run pulling work off a
queue
right but you can scale each one of
those items quite independently of each
other
so think quite often about a model that
processes tasks and activities you can
if you want to use something like value
stream mapping to figure out your
process changing your organization
and what you want to do is think hey
what things actually could occur in
parallel at different steps of looking
like my production line where I'm just
passing work down
to get processed
good idea of coordinating our data flow
orchestrating a continuous study flow of
information focusing on division by
Behavior not structure
sort of about Pat Helen
so Pat Helen basically is an
architecture Amazon Microsoft you should
probably go and read most of his papers
if you haven't he's exceptionally
influential in terms of the world of
autonomous computing
so when we think about what this process
does I find it helpful to think about
Pat's model of basically what happens
inside a component and Pat basically had
this idea of an activity
so at the bottom so an activity is
basically a state machine and it says
I've received a message I should do
something in response probably I may I
may choose to update a resource so
resources some thing that belongs to the
business that I manage I don't know uh
restaurants couriers right
and I typically also have some I may
have some say about an activity if I'm
my state machine for some point I need
to actually say well I'm going to stop
the state machine there in order to wait
for a response from a different node
I may have to save the state of my state
machine into database I'll come back to
that in a second you may not need to
so the activity is generally this
combination of code that I run in
response to an input signal
and any state I need to store about my
activity to allow me to resume it if I
crash I need to pause for any reason
there is an explicit boundary
in other words the things inside my
activity State my resource State they
are not exposed to the outside world
right that means effectively I know who
is effectively going to be basically
reading and writing tour I could choose
to be single threaded right for example
because I don't need and I know there's
no need to worry about synchronization
because effectively aren't any person
writing to it I also protect these
resources their schemas Etc such that I
can change them and nobody outside cares
they only care about the thing that
comes on the input port and the thing
that leaves by the output port
so you might have a model like this
right purchase comes in on my input Port
I begin my activity so I say I need to
check out what do I do I validate the
order is that is that a valid you know
can the restaurant still cook that
sometimes restaurants take things off
menus for us because they run out of the
ingredients necessary to cook it right
then basically we may by price it
pricing may involve offers right you
know currently it's a it's a cheeky
Tuesday offer and you're going to get 15
off
then what we want to do is request
payment for this order right so what we
do is we just basically pause our steak
machine save some State saying hey we
reached the point of payment mode and we
send a message
saying hey let's grab the payment for
that please
that goes through our output off into
the ether
right
then the next component as the pricing
when it responds
comes back by a different port
right it comes back by Port saying
priced order
we can use a correlation idea typically
to look up that particular piece of
activity so where did we get to oh yeah
we basically had requested payment looks
like the payment's been made I can move
this order on and I can send another
signal for example saying New Order and
that will then go to order placement
yeah
so I'm building just like in data flow
programming kind of black box which I
then effectively have these activities
inside and they just communicate with
outside world by messaging
I need to worry about transactional
messaging
because well actually it should be my
activity really more than my other
resource but if I'm effectively saying
hey I suspended my workflow at the point
of making a requested payment
I need to send that message
generally one of the problems that I hit
is I can't effectively usually have a
transaction that spans both my
messaging provider my broker be that
basically Kafka rabbit SNS Azure service
bus whatever you use and the resource
where I'm storing probably more my
activity State than resource state right
in order to make sure that those two are
in sync so that if effectively I say I
have requested basically the payment
there has been a corresponding message I
want a transaction the way I do that is
I create an outbox so generally a table
in the same place effectively I'm
managing my activity State and I write
the message there
and a sweeper usually some kind of
separate thread
looks through the outbox for unsent
messages and sends them for me
and it keeps doing that on a regular
interval
and eventually even if the broker is
temporarily down or unavailable it will
send it
because it ain't gonna mark it sent
until it's gone
so at that point I can guarantee that I
have transactional messaging there are
risks I don't want to get into that
today let's not talk about outbox that
effectively I can duplicate sending
because I don't get to write basically
back to the outbox so we call it
guaranteed at least once we call it
guaranteed at least once because you
have to accept the presence of
duplicates
and that means I tend to want an inbox
an inbox so I can de-duplicate have I
seen this piece of work before
if I have seen this work piece of work
before I probably shouldn't process it
and what's really useful about this is
essentially this component can crash
if it crashes
before it's basically sent a message to
the app onto the broker when it comes
back up there's no dispatch to entering
the outbox so I'll keep trying to resend
it
because I can guarantee that I've got
messaging and other components have
inboxes so they cope with duplicates
I'm okay with these components crashing
okay
interestingly enough
I may not even actually need to save
activity state
if I have an inbox and an out box I
actually have a record of the
conversation that I've been engaged
about particular activity
I know what I've received and I know
what I sent
I could recalculate what activities are
currently in flight because I say well I
received all these and I haven't sent
those messages out so they didn't reach
that point or this one reached that
point and I'm waiting for a response for
it so you can recalculate it you don't
have to necessarily do that but in some
cases you might want to see that as an
optimization
so generally these things are sequenced
together so here are effectively my
price goes over to take payment take
payment does its work at some point
basically it says a payment was made
that comes back on a different port I
Advanced the workflow in my state
machine so the purchase has been made
and then I raise a new order
even if that basically is an error
that's just another message being raised
if the customer's car was declined
because effectively they'd taken the
card off basically some form in the
deepest darkest parts of the internet
then it turns out basically that's okay
I guess the payment refused message and
we effectively then would just raise a
request new card message right
so everything is just messages flowing
back and forth
now
interestingly enough like we said what
this protects us from is when we looked
at the early idea that basically entity
Services thoughts would propagate
because we have
asynchronous conversations between these
components
work simply cues
so if it crashes my take payment module
I simply queue up payment requests
when it comes back online
it'll start basically honoring those
payment requests for me
so we'll talk about this being a
bulkhead to failure
Bowl coaches are on a ship I have these
watertight compartments
if I receive a hole in the compartment
which is the compartment floods the
whole ship doesn't sink right they take
payments is down that's a problem for
the team on call for take payments but
it doesn't necessarily mean the checkout
team have to scramble their work's just
building up hopefully the key won't get
too long before we basically introduce a
new instance to take payment it works by
the way don't be the Titanic the Titanic
basically for it's because it's first
class passengers didn't want to have to
navigate those hatches on bulkheads it
stopped its bulkheads short of the top
of the ship so first class passengers
could allegedly stroll along the deck
and the problem with that is when one of
your bulkheads gets a hole in it the
water floods over the top through the
first class basically a passenger
compartment and your ship sinks so be
wary of that
probably our closest example to making
holes for the first class passengers is
this idea sometimes you see people get
all the way to doing that model and then
they go oh I need a pricing model to
price with how am I going to get that
and they forget
that I'm building my model in a reactive
style where effectively I have data flow
programming style knows measures between
them I'll just do a get request and get
the pricing model
which is of course a bad idea because
now effectively I've just reintroduced a
dependency basically on a synchronous
component that if it faults brings down
my checkout component right now
admittedly only checkout is probably
down at this point it may not be so bad
everything else is queuing but we can
still work around that right one option
might be well I send the model a request
to a pricing components they kind of
have the pricing model for this
restaurant and it replies and gives it
back to me but in this kind of data like
pricing models for restaurants actually
I'm going to be asking for that a lot
so the other alternative is to think
about that model from flowbase
programming of a lookup table
and we say well I tell you what the
pricing component whenever it basically
creates a new pricing model a new
catalog or a menu if you like
it sends out a message I'll listen for
those and I'll store them in a database
locally to me
and I can just look up the pricing
because it's not an activity I want to
parallelize
and so essentially I don't really want
to put my workflow into basically I
don't want to basically shut it down and
say save it save the state aware my
activity wait for the pricing model to
come back it's quite inefficient
right I just want to price it there and
then
so I can give you the data
that you can then use to price it by
listening to the event stream that's
coming out of the pricing module that
says hey here are some facts about
prices
remember this idea we have two things
that we can the messages may be an
instruction for us to do something
please do this purchase something or
things that you should know like a
pricing model
it turns out what I do with that is I
save it so I can look it up later this
general idea is called event card State
transfer
well that means the pricing model is
down
I'm resilient to that too
sure the prices are a bit stale
but that's generally okay right maybe
you get a cheap pizza
we live with that
they're another whole Forums on the
internet dedicated to how you rip
Justice off by the way
um so we sometimes we can tailor the
consistency here right we can decide
what's our ability to live with
something that maybe eventually
consistent there might be a little bit
out of date if that's okay maybe we can
use some technique like a lookout for
our ecst maybe we can't really live with
that and I have to send you a message
and get a response but you can tailor
the consistency that you're willing to
accept an individual component
we alluded to this earlier
let it crash right it comes from the
actor model this idea that we say hey
the simplest thing for us to do is to
accept now in the event of a failure we
support us rapidly crash our
applications
recovery is hard writing all that code
that figures out I wonder what state
we're currently in and I wonder how I
can unwind this mess it's probably
fraught with error and Peril right
because generally speaking you don't
know enough and what happens if you
crash by trying to recover from the
crash right it's a bit of a nightmare
generally a huge number of crashes it
turns out you can just get resolved by
basically saying let's just kill this
system and basically reboot it
right turn it on and off again works for
notes as well as anything else but to do
that we have to make sure that startup
basically is recovery
when we start up we figure out where
should we be
and shutdown is clean when I shut down I
don't leave things in a state I can't
recover too
so some simple rules
if I'm pulling something off basically
the input buffer don't hack it don't say
I'm done with it
until I've sent a corresponding output
message updated my activity state to the
right place marked it in my inbox
until that point
what will happen is if I crash the work
will still be on the Queue and I can
simply pick up the work again and try it
again
all right so don't Mark that individual
piece of work done until we've done it
do you duplicate because somebody else
may be sending this duplicates because
they've been using transactional
messaging to make sure that we're going
to receive the messages that correspond
to the state they've currently reached
and use asynchronous messaging because
that allows us basically to let them
crash and we just queue work for them
we're not dependent on their uptime we
haven't forced them to be available we
just want availability of this increased
messaging it'll work
we may need to apply back pressure
just as we did with basically actor
models
if we have to control the rate at which
we can basically can consume stuff
generally it means we've got a resource
that basically is limiting its capacity
so maybe we're using a database with a
jdbc connection coming out of a pool
we've got a limited number of
Connections in the pool right
two ways applying back pressure
depending whether we're push or pull to
the messaging middleware
if basically it's pull very
straightforward we reduce the rate of
polling so that we don't effectually get
too many messages if it's push typically
middleware tends to support the idea of
only X many messages in flight
so if I have a certain number of unac
messages it won't send me more
we may also want to think about a
circuit breaker right right in the event
the stuff that we did that we own is
struggling with the load then just
basically stop taking messages
wait until a certain product amount of
time has passed try a test if that one
goes through hey open the floodgates and
let everybody else back in
or return to the load shed
right so in the event that this resource
is struggling that's okay I'll just
discard incoming messages and I'll wait
until basically it recovers
we can also think about the idea of
being single threaded
if our components tend to basically be
single threaded and reading from the
queue and writing to the output they're
very easy for us to reason about the
software Engineers don't have to worry
about uh generalizing access to mutable
state
we don't have to worry about context
switching
uh the open source framework I work on
brighter we are single threaded you can
have more instances of us but we're
single threaded and we scale far better
than the complicated schemes I've seen
where people write them with thread
pools and stuff it's all a nightmare
right try to be single threaded if I'm
single threaded I obviously have to
think about the fact of well if I
introduce more instances of them
am I now at risk basically of trying to
update things out of order because I'm
pulling work from two threads from a
stream type things out of order so
earlier about Kafka Cafe lets you read
with one thread through partitions so if
you need ordering when you choose to
scale out a single threaded item then
effectively you have to rely on
partitioning of some sort active models
do different form but they still do
partitioning effectively when they root
right if you don't care about ordering
if I can process these items
individually I can just scale out
without worrying about I can have a cue
or the light that doesn't necessarily
need to support partitioning right
okay
so I can scale out
these components
which means if I let something crash
it's pretty easy for some kind of
supervisor
to just create new instances to continue
to meet my workload and that's what you
get kubernetes from or other you know
other forms of elastic basically compute
that will introduce new instances in
order to cope with instances that have
gone down
and overall
that gives us this idea of
responsiveness
this idea essentially that's a hard
diagram to read this idea that
effectively if we have components
that essentially communicate via
asynchronous messaging and therefore
have bulkheads to failures of other
components and can easily be scaled out
such that as components begin to fail we
can just introduce new instances in
order to replace them we tend to be
responsive to users because we can both
scale to meet load on demand and we can
remain working
despite failure
which gets us back to this diagram
which is really where active
architectures come from which says if we
choose to build applications that use
messaging as the means to communicate
between the different nodes of our
application we will gain the benefits of
resilience
because we have bulkheads to failure
elasticity particularly if we have a
kind of let it crash pattern where
essentially we just basically restart
new components in order to cope with a
failure of existing ones or essentially
to cope with increased load or also to
encode with decreased load and reduce
our cost
right and that makes us responsive to
users
and all of that really
comes from us reapplying some of these
ideas from the 1970s that came and
people were trying to think hard about
how we would cope with a model that had
multiple cores and not necessarily the
classic one human architectures that
were prevalent at the time
all right and I'm done
I don't think
we have much time for questions I think
I'm bang on time but as I'm packing up
if you've got a question
thanks very much